the stage is now set for an historic
Senate showdown over Supreme Court
nominee Neil Gorsuch 43 senators now say
they will vote no that is more than
enough to support a democratic
filibuster to try to block the
nomination Republican leaders are ready
to change Senate rules and use the
so-called nuclear option to make sure
Gossage it's confirmed Jen Crawford is
on Capitol Hill dan good morning good
morning so Democrats are saying that
Republicans are about to forever change
long-standing Senate rules but it was
Democrats who voted back in 2013 to end
filibusters for lower court judges in
cabinet level appointees so Republicans
are saying their protests now don't mean
a whole lot Hamilton is rolling over in
his grave frustrated by their democratic
colleagues Republicans on the Judiciary
Committee say they will not allow a
filibuster on the nomination of Judge
Neil Gorsuch there has never been a
successful partisan filibuster of a
Supreme Court nominee and we will not
start this week it takes 60 votes to
stop a filibuster an end debate on a
nomination with 52 votes in the Senate
Republicans have fallen short of
securing support from eight Democrats
and I have said they will trigger the
nuclear option which will blow up the
rules and do away with filibusters for
Supreme Court nominees I'll be agree
justice back in February president Trump
said he would support the break-in
president but if we end up with that
gridlock I would say if you can Mitch
cono clear I have fulfilled my
constitutional duty Democrats say
president Trump's shouldn't be filling
the vacancy blasting Republicans for
refusing to confirm President Obama's
nominee Merrick garland last year all I
can say is what goes around comes around
but they are also concerned about the
long-term implications of going nuclear
I think
a number of my colleagues have grave
misgivings about the destructive
repercussions
decades come Judiciary Committee
Chairman chuck Grassley says he has no
concerns about changing the rules I'm
going to do whatever it takes to get
gorgeous on the Supreme Court now if
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell does
decide to go nuclear and change the
rules he could formally bring up the
nomination today a final vote would be
on Friday and judge courses would be
confirmed to the Supreme Court with the
simple majority Nora all right we'll be
watching Jim thank you so much